[Music]
right one of the most highly anticipated
games Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the
switch exclusive is in the building
cannot wait to see this huge fan of
Marvel Ultimate Alliance and we're bout
to see what's going on right now
the basic attack system looks like we
got synergy attacks abilities might be
heavy return jump button as usual we got
camera controls and I believe that
heroic camera so very looking forwards
at that
we all set this demo off y'all
all right we got the floor right now
looks like we've got my man Thor
Wolverine Captain Marvel and of course
the legendary star more from the
guardians of the galaxy
in Shadowland
the SharePoint
switch our characters yeah
look at all we got black path in the
middle in all right Miles Morales all
right let's go
[Music]
the last group played the other one
nice
so just like the original looks like you
can use the shield access point that's
where you switch out that's a kind of a
vintage Marvel Ultimate Alliance de
bourree years ago Jessica Jones
[Applause]
this was shadow live to get a
multi-platform leveling design
[Music]
you break Berkeley to fight
looks like those red and blue orbs are
bagged one for the abilities of
liability usage and hopefully we get to
see some ultimate abilities where
characters will combine they use synergy
attacks
hold the harbor
and you'd be ever notice in there
mother fog on
really nice stuff city jeez they're back
that's good
love those city cheese man so you can
get like Captain America
classic stuff from Ultimate Alliance 2
needs to have that as well
all without flying ability looking very
godly
local side-scrolling filler
clocks about cars or depressed hell
Dodge
love this very level Shadowland level
for daredevil fans this is huge to hide
ninjas all men behave excuse me kids has
been classic walk Aikido stuff
please
yeah
[Music]
or you want to try to collect
still got the ability to roll item
we have a stealth aspect to it
[Music]
this level they want to avoid being
excited about it
but if you wanna get
Oh
[Music]
when you're jumping at
Piderman if you hold down
nice
if more people are trying to
that line though it's awesome like all
Africa critique lies
let's go yeah
snores also really hard
annum
[Music]
I was trying to
yeah yeah we gotta get that black
panther that's a good idea good idea
let's get one convey in here there we go
yeah let's see what bad they can do nice
love the little cinematic cutscenes
I don't know
you should just go push the button cc'
drunk she drunk Jamie door like
Oh Oh venom okay advice
[Music]
item acquired interesting
item system
you pick up you can equip them to your
heroes okay and know
like buff abilities elicit likes for
specific abilities that they boss
increase your vitality okay gosh yeah it
was a classic mob Ultimate Alliance not
attribute that's really cool
you're gonna start when it's just
tougher here
and you knock that down you'll be able
to stun your head
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you have another
okay gotcha
it looks like three and then the
ultimate ability I'm assuming
soon we'll use
I can't wait their way as another
ultimate alive stable those Ultimates
love the camera angle changes
single player you can actually control
the camera movements cries multi player
is Mars is that the legendary date here
and the immortal iron fist
okay
nice
there's other bars yellow bar around
your icon
if you press L&R at the same
see those old Smith
see it blinking over there eat the
present
you do that again you'll get the
computer player
knife
[Music]
but it'll try to get pretty good here so
you can use it a couple
okay pepper
okay okay
oh here we go
okay cool
also Marvel Ultimate Alliance three very
cool they think they seem pleased get
out and wait for it to drop another Iowa
Park has exclusive cannot waive an
absolute pleasure they deserve
[Music]